no no make it stop make it stop
okay so this video we're going to be
breaking down the new ryan reynolds
tweet
that teases an appearance of green
lantern in the snyder cut
and also a little copyright claim i
received that
could confirm the snyder cut is going to
be released in episodic format
i'm just going to get straight into the
news because i don't want to waste any
more of your life
but if you enjoyed this video then
please drop a thumbs up and don't forget
to subscribe for videos like this every
day anyway
yesterday you may have seen that the
cultured nerd dropped a report saying
that ryan reynolds was being eyed for
the role of hawkman
in the upcoming black had a movie don't
know why i just called him hawkman there
very very posh now this was reportedly
alongside
charlie hunnam vin diesel and michael b
jordan
so as you can see they were casting a
specific
type by the looks of it now the report
said that sources close to the cultured
nerd
had told them that ryan reynolds was in
the running for the role
and this quickly lit up the internet
shortly after grace randolph said
this obviously wasn't true and that the
real hawkman casting news
was gonna be gracing us very soon
personally
whenever i see the words being eyed for
i do take it with a grain of salt and
this report was no different
it's a phrase i've used myself back in
my more clickbait days
and it's something that writers tend to
put in articles when they want
deniability
when it doesn't come true what do you
mean i'm still as clickbait as ever well
anyway
seeing this and then the other
potentials alongside it it just seemed
far too scattered to make any sense and
people like umberto gonzalez shutting it
down
quickly shut it down in my mind too also
vin diesel in the rock absolutely hate
each other
so i really can't see them featuring in
black adam together
on top of this the main man himself ryan
reynolds shut this rumor down
and today he tweeted the following i'm
not playing hawkman in black adam
i don't know why he sounds like michael
jackson although i do generally do
whatever the hell the rock tells me to
i would however love to be in zack
snyder's justice league movie
and i've heard i may already be in it
hashtag snydercut
so a lot to take from that and the first
thing is that the actor will not be
appearing as hawkman in black adam
however the last sentence it it does
tease quite a lot you must admit
now we will be talking about the
reported ending of the snyder cut
so if you don't want to know anything
then i'll leave a time code in the
description below so you can skip to the
mini series section of the video
anyway if you're still here in the
original ending of justice league
green lantern and martian manhunter were
supposedly going to reveal themselves to
bruce wayne
and this would set up justice league
part 2 in which both characters were big
members of the group
as reynolds is the last actor to play
green lantern
it was thought that he may take up the
position though
rumors of army hammer also circulated
around the same time
at the end of crisis on infinite earths
the green lanterns were teased
and with the release of the snyder cut
it did seem like dc were indeed heading
towards the character popping up down
the line
so there is a possibility that reynolds
could be appearing at the end of the
movie
but you can also take this tweet the
exact opposite way
personally i'm still a bit skeptical on
this and it may be in fact
just the actor trolling people as he's
often known to do
the snyder cut has been shot and
finished since 2017
and though zack is trying to shoot some
new scenes for it
with everything that's going on it may
be unlikely that he ever actually
manages to get them done
so the fact that reynolds isn't sure if
he's in it or not
doesn't quite confirm that he's in it to
me it
makes sense doesn't it now this is him
simply putting it out here that he would
like to be in it
and that he has of course seen the
rumors circulating that he will be
putting the cgi costume back on
and slipping his finger into a green
ring last time i did that though it was
it was to a bird in southport and it led
to me getting scary what
now i think this can of course be taken
the other way in that reynolds may have
even filmed scenes for the film
and he's still unsure whether they will
be used personally i lean more towards
him
not being in it due to the price that
the actor would demand for a cameo
and the contract that this appearance
would tie him to for movies and films
down the line for
which he might never get out of now that
doesn't mean it's out of the realms of
possibility though
and i also wouldn't be surprised if he
did show up
if it was any other actor i would take
this as confirmation
but with it being reynolds who's
generally known for keeping his tongue
placed firmly in his cheek
it really could go either way obviously
leave your thoughts on the situation in
the comments section below
how you take this tweet and also what
your favorite green lantern cgi costume
is
now under the next bit of news and as
i'm sure you're aware
there was a tiny tiny little snyder cut
clip dropped last week
that pretty much broke the internet more
than a heavy spoilers face reveal
yes he's another clean-shaven white dude
with brown hair
that does comic book movie videos we
pretty much come off an assembly line to
raise money for youtube anyway i myself
uploaded the clip to the channel
so that my wonderful subscribers could
get the first look at the suit
if they missed the panel as with most
youtube videos
when you don't add any commentary or
your own thoughts on a clip or something
they're claimed by the studio who then
run ads on the video
and collect the revenue typically you
receive an email to alert you to this
and what's interesting about the one for
the justice league clip is that they
said the clip was from justice league
episode n1
so the original file that was uploaded
to youtube has this name
and it does potentially add a lot of
weight to the idea that justice league
could be a mini-series
we do know that the run time of the
entire thing will be in the three and a
half hour area
and with this being a streaming service
wb will probably not want people to end
their trial
after they've watched it thus they may
drag it out for six weeks in episodic
format
to get more subscriptions and make it so
that people have to pay for at least the
first month
now i did post this email last week and
it blew up a bit on twitter
with lots of people saying it confirms
the miniseries and others saying that it
doesn't
i've gone back and forth on it and
personally i don't think it confirms
anything
but it is very interesting initially i
did think this may just be a tease of
justice league part 2
which could be called episode 2 on some
star wars shiz
but now i think it might just be a file
name for example
i will probably upload this video and
call the file justice league snyder cup
breakdown trailer green lantern cameo
ryan reynolds hawkman just because
there's keywords in that
and it'll help with the seo however the
fact that tf1 antennas
also claimed it alongside warner
brothers does tease something
now i looked up that name and it's a
french television channel
and with hbo max being exclusive to the
us
the channel may have potentially bought
the television rights to show the film
in france
so there is that now where this doesn't
make sense is that the clip we saw is
clearly later in the movie
and it was due to take place just before
the final battle
so its appearance in episode 1 it
doesn't make sense
unless the movie opens with a flash
forward perhaps it will show to the
audience
exactly what they're in store for and
also tease fans that this will be true
to the director's vision
with us finally getting the black suit
it could also be a trailer at the end of
the first episode
and yeah there are possibilities so that
it does work if you want it to
now since posting the tweet i've had a
lot of people coming back and forth in
the comments saying what they think
and it is definitely interesting to
consider we will reportedly find out the
full length and format of the film at
this month's dc fandom
and it's very exciting to know that we
will know soon enough so i can stop
making click bait videos like this
also yeah speaking of clickbait i do
love the fact that there's lots of
celebs shutting down rumors at the
moment
shout outs ryan reynolds and james gunn
you're doing god's work right now
anyway that's the video obviously i'd
love to hear your thoughts on it
so make sure you comment below and let
me know if you missed our breakdown of
the new superman black suit clip
and the zack snyder justice comp panel
and make sure you check it out after
this
as we go into everything that you need
to know about it don't forget that every
month on the 15th we give away free
blu-rays and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning the mcu infinity
saga box set
is leave a like drop a comment and
subscribe with notifications on
yes yes i know this is a dc video and
it's a marvel giveaway
now if you want to support the channel
and get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat to us on our
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter
thanks for making it until the end of
the video you've been the best
i've been definition i'll see you next
time hopefully
i hope i hope i'll see you soon now take
care
peace
[Music]
you